Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the lifelong podcast.
Are you joking?
No.
I was always fixated on the word lifelong.
You want this to be a lifelong podcast?
Yeah, man.
Hey, we're gonna do it forever.
Yeah, we're gonna do this forever.
Welcome to Ear Biscuits,
the podcast where two
lifelong best friends
talk about life for a long time.
I'm Link.
I'm Rhett.
You added best again, which I don't,
I don't have any problem
anytime you add best
because we are best friends.
Yeah, it feels good.
I just, the reason I don't add
it is because it feels like
it messes up like the flow a
little bit, but it is true,
so you might as well say it.
I did say it and I'm not taking it back
and I don't need your approval.
I'm Rhett, I'm Link's best friend.
And this week at the round
table of dim lighting
we're gonna be talking
about my camping trip.
Your solo excursion into,
I mean, I have all these
pictures in my mind
of this bearded tall man in loincloth
out in the deserts of Nevada.
Pretty much got it right.
Except no loincloth.
We had this whole buildup
about how this was for you
and it's not necessarily for
me or for anyone listening.
So we need to get into all that.
But I hope you can tell
us enough because--
I'll tell you enough.
I've been picturing a lot
and I needed to, I need it.
You might be building things up too much.
How do you want to do this?
Slowly, methodically.
No, eh, I have a lot to
say about my experience.
I do want to say upfront,
and we talked about,
you know, the build up to this was like
this is about me kind of going out
and having this time with myself,
it's about self discovery.
And I was very, especially
because my mission
was to not have a mission.
My agenda was to have no agenda, right?
And my sort of approach was
to separate the trip from
it needing to be translated
into an entertaining story.
Right, because again, that
just kind of brings the focus
back onto me in a negative way,
not in like an enriching
way, but in a selfish,
hey, here's what I got to say.
Here's what I'm gonna bring
back from the mountain top,
kind of way.
And I didn't want that.
I tried really hard the
entire time I was out there
to make sure that I'm not making decisions
or writing things down
with an audience in mind
because I live my life in a lot of ways
with an audience in mind,
it's part of the job, right?
And this whole trip was
not about the audience,
it was about me.
So I am going to, I'm
gonna talk more about,
I'm gonna talk about some
of the fun and practical
things that happened,
some of the, you know,
I am gonna talk about
one update that I have
based on the conversation that
we had, the argument podcast,
we had a couple episodes ago.
The sports, sportsmanship.
Sportsmanship.
I thought you were such a good sportsman.
I insisted that you
were a great sportsman.
And I didn't believe I
was a good sportsman.
Am I competitive or not.
When I tried to prove to you
over the course of an hour,
that you were competitive,
we're gonna talk about
an updated perspective
that I have on that.
But I will say up top that
what I would say are some very significant
emotional, and dare I say,
spiritual things occurred
that I will not be talking about.
Okay, yeah, I respect that.
'Cause if you went into those
things, then I would be like,
well, that really hits it on the head
of what you said you didn't want to do.
So you're going to talk around
the thing that was most
meaningful for you.
The only reason I'm saying
that is because again,
I went into the desert for,
I would say for spiritual reasons.
Yeah, I mean, for emotional
slash spiritual reasons
and it was an incredibly enriching,
incredibly fruitful time.
From the very beginning,
I thought that I was gonna to have to wait
until day three or something
but even the first morning of camping,
it was just a very enriching time.
But again, I almost feel
like it sells it short
to talk about, it also
makes it about me trying to,
it's not about me having anything to share
and any wisdom or anything like that.
It was just something
that happened with me,
that I might talk about
at some point in my life
or on this podcast, I don't know,
but that's not what
this is gonna be about.
I get it, I get it.
I think that's a good choice.
I don't want to cheapen
anything that happened
by making it into a podcast.
Can I cheapen it?
Yeah, you can cheapen it all you want.
No, but seriously, there
are some things in my mind,
I'll just throw out some questions now
that you can answer at any point you want.
Okay.
Because I did find myself thinking,
especially in the first
two nights of me camping,
I found myself thinking about,
I wonder what Rhett's situation is,
because like I said, I was out,
Christie and I were camping in
the most isolated situations
I've ever been in.
I mean, 'cause even when I
did my solo trip to slab city,
there was like someone renting
out this abandoned RV to me
and I had contact with people
and I was on the edge of a
city, I was never this alone.
And I was assuming you were that alone
and I knew that last time, and again,
you wrote about it in
the Book of Mythicality,
you got really scared that one night.
That's one thing that I found myself,
like just being swallowed by the darkness.
You know, and the stars.
Does your wife being there
making you less scared?
Oh, of course.
And then I'm like,
'cause what I would tell
Christie, I was like,
I wonder what Rhett's doing?
She was like, why do you
keep talking about Rhett?
It's like, because he doesn't
have you or Jesse there.
Like, I have you, I'm
like, you know, it's.
I think that's my main question is like,
how scared did you get?
You don't have to start there.
And then I'm curious about
the hot springs and like,
I was concerned that like you didn't,
I knew you were gonna,
you wanted to be at a hot spring alone.
I don't know how easy that is so I was,
but I was hopeful for you.
So that was the, so again,
the idea of the trip just from
a practical standpoint was,
I've got my old FJ
Cruiser, 2007 FJ Cruiser,
it's only got 100,000 miles on it
but I recently just got some work on it.
Took it in to get the---
That's an understatement
based on the price tag you told me.
I basically bought a new
car by restoring this car.
Did I technically own half
of that car at one point?
Yeah, but I bought it from you.
Okay.
And you bought the Scion from me.
I got the FJ Cruiser, you got he Scion.
But it wasn't the same
amount of money, was it?
Don't worry about it, go ahead.
No, actually we probably,
we paid more for the Scion
than I paid for the FJ Cruiser.
But I'm kinda glad I got the FJ Cruiser.
Anyway, so I just put
this new rooftop tent
on the FJ Cruiser and again, like I said,
got a bunch of work done
because when I took it
and I was like, I'm taking
this thing across the country.
They were like, well you
need new blank, blank, blank,
blank, blank, blank, blank, blank, blank,
lots of money went into this thing.
You don't want to get stranded.
But it's basically like,
do I want to continue to use this vehicle
as my off-roading vehicle indefinitely
Or do I wanna get like the new Bronco
or something like that when it comes out?
And so I decided to throw
the money at the old car,
which is less than a new car, anyway.
I mean, I spent weeks
getting ready for this trip
and like I've got these like drawers,
not like the cool, nicely
installed, you know,
you can get like--
It's not a sprinter van, I mean.
But you can get custom made,
pull out rollout drawers
that go in the back of SUVs.
And they're made specifically
for the different SUVs,
'cause I had all this, you know,
all these tools and all this stuff
to be able to survive
on my own indefinitely,
or for six days.
But I ended up just getting
like $25 plastic Sterilite drawers
that faced each other in the back.
This is where we're starting,
we're talking about plastic drawers.
I put everything in there to be ready
and I was super excited
about this rooftop tent
and the idea being that you
literally can drive anywhere
that's public land or national forest land
and as long as you find
a spot off of the road,
you can just camp, right?
And most of the, we call it
disperse camping and there's,
you know, Oh, there's a fire
ring, somebody's been here.
And I use the same app that you did,
the eye Overlander app, early
recommendation, I guess,
because you can find some places
that people have been, whatever.
So the idea was to
loosely follow this route,
that would take me to some hot springs
that had been recommended to me
but also some that I kind of
just found on another app,
there's a hot springs app
that shows you every thermal springs
in the entire United States
and the temperature and a
little bit of information,
but basically it shows you the coordinates
and then you can kind
of just navigate to it
and check it out.
And there's a lot of 'em
in California and Nevada,
it turns out.
But, and the day before my,
two days before the trip,
all the national forests
in California closed.
Closed down, yeah,
'cause of so many fires.
And they're like, the forest are closed,
no camping, no hiking,
you can't go in there.
And I'm like, well damn it,
my route is taking me up through
all these national forests
and what am I gonna do?
Am I gonna just go somewhere else?
And I was like, screw it,
I'll just go that way.
And first of all, there's the BLM land,
The Bureau of Land Management,
we talked about in your
episode, which surrounds,
mostly it's like corridors of interstates
and stuff like that.
These kind of before you
get further off the highway
into national forest,
and that wasn't closed.
It had all the fire restrictions in place,
you couldn't have a campfire,
but you could have a stove.
So I head up north and I
just had this loose idea
that I wasn't gonna make it,
I wasn't gonna make myself
have to make it to a hot
spring on the first day.
Because I felt like
making it to a hot spring on the first day
was to accomplishment oriented.
You know what I'm saying?
Like, having to get to a place
and do the thing that's a thing.
And then if you don't then you failed.
Right, take it a little bit slow.
And so I stopped at a place,
you may have seen this sign
before going up to Mammoth,
Alabama Hills.
Nu-uh.
First of all, when I sent the text
from my satellite device
to my wife I said,
I'm camping in the Alabama Hills.
I mean, she was like,
how the hell did you get
to Alabama in five hours?
But that's just the name of
'em, they're in California.
And it's like, you know how Joshua Tree
has these crazy rock formations
and just giant boulders
stacked on top of each other
that have, you know, kind
of everything's eroded away.
And they're these crazy like almost car
to small house sized rocks
that are stacked on top of each other
that are super easy to climb.
Same exact material, same exact process
that happened in Joshua Tree
has happened in this little place
right outside of a Lone Pine.
Okay.
Lone Pine, California is like,
if you believe, there's
like the film museum there
because they've shot so
many things in Lone Pine
because the mountains can
look like the Himalayas.
So they've shot the
mountains in California,
right there next to Lone
Pine as the Himalayas
in all kinds of movies.
Oh.
Talkin' about like Mount
Whitney and all that?
Yeah, and if you go by, you know,
'cause we go to Mammoth to
ski and as you take that trip,
a lot of times you're like,
man, that looks like the Himalayas.
Somebody who doesn't know
what the Himalayas look like.
Right.
But there's just so many movies
that have been shot there.
And this Alabama Hills,
a bunch of movies have been shot there
'cause it has like a
Martian kind of, you know,
just sort of this
different sort of landscape
sort of feel to it.
Anyway, so I get there
and it was one of those
remote, but not completely remote.
Like the park is,
you know, it's a few
square miles or whatever,
but there's just a bunch of dirt roads
that go up to these big boulders
and there'll be a fire ring there.
And I'm like driving around
like, ah, somebody there.
I'm gonna keep going.
Oh, somebody at this one.
And eventually I found one
that somebody wasn't at
and it was like a giant sort of cul-de-sac
with this big rock and
then this rock wall,
kind of U shaped rock wall that
had like a name on the map,
it was like for rock climbers.
I think it was called like the
Loaf or something like that.
It's like seven, eight stories
tall of these giant rocks.
And so I was like, okay, I'm here.
Like I can, like, if the person
at the camp site next to me,
turns their car on, I can hear that.
And if they yell, I can hear that,
but I can't see them because
they're over this like rock
sort of facade.
That's good.
No line of sight, that's what you want.
And I can like play music at my campsite
and they can't really hear it,
like it'd have to be pretty loud.
Yeah.
So I was like, it turns out
that that is the sweet spot
as I will get to when you
are too close to somebody
or when you're too far away from somebody,
you get a whole different problem.
Which I did for two nights,
I'll talk about that.
But that first day I like parked the car,
get the rooftop tent opened up,
get everything set up,
put my little table out.
And then I just, like, I'm
gonna climb these rocks.
Why not, right?
And I just start, I go up
to the rocks and I just,
first of all, I'm thinking
about snakes constantly.
It's amazing how the older you get,
the more you think about all
the things that could go wrong.
When I was a child--
You're gettin' an enema from a snake.
Well, that's not how it works.
As a child, you know, as a kid growing up
we're just like swimming
in the Cape Fear River,
stepping on water moccasins,
not thinking about anything.
And I'm like walking
along and like clapping.
I'm like, they can hear clapping, right?
Stamping really hard, if
somebody was to see me,
like, what is he trying to do?
I think they hear heat.
No they hear vibrations, so
I'm trying to make vibrations.
'Cause I know it's gonna
be a rattlesnake probably
if I see one.
And I'm like, are they
still out this time of year?
I think so, it's still pretty hot.
But eventually I climb up,
I get to the almost
freaking top of this thing
and there's a little
place to pass through.
And I pass through and come
into this other valley of,
there was nothing but these giant rocks
and I was like, this is wonderful.
What?
This is like a cathedral.
And I just sat down on a rock.
You passed through to the other side.
And I just sat there and I was like,
this is going to be a good trip.
But it doesn't have to be,
'cause I don't want an agenda.
Did you have water?
I'd have been thinking, I need water.
I mean, I was still,
I was 200 yards from my car at that point.
Like it was, I had just gone up the rocks
so I didn't have
anything, I had my camera.
Were you talking to yourself yet?
A little bit, whispering maybe.
Oh.
Because I thought people
might be able to hear me.
Okay.
But I go back down, I
cook myself some dinner.
My food situation was a
lot of those pre-packaged,
just add water.
Okay.
Because I was like, the cleanup is minimal
and you're really hungry
and everything tastes
good when you're camping
so maybe I'll be able
to get away with this.
Survival packs.
And what I did is before
the trip I was like,
I'm gonna try a bunch of different brands.
So I got, you know, Mountain House,
that's the one everybody
knows about, right,
that's that's the super popular one.
And then there's another one
that I ended up liking the
most, just if you're interested.
I think it's called Packet
Gourmet or something,
it's got the story of like
the couple that started it in the 70s
and now they've got kids
and they all work there.
They make some really good grits.
You know, when you put water in something
that's has got meat in
it sometimes it's like,
man, this is like meat
that could have been around until 2050.
Yeah.
That can't be great for you
and it definitely isn't great
tasting, but the grits, man.
They got a grit, they got multiple grits.
Packet, Packet People, Packet House?
Yeah, yeah, Packet Gourmet, I don't know.
Anyway, I had one of those, I was like,
Hmm, it's pretty good.
And then the sun's about
to set at this point.
Sun's going down, I take out my journal
and I decided I'm gonna
do the handwritten thing
even though I'm probably
gonna get hand cramps,
'cause that happens to me.
Rattlesnakes and hand cramps.
I Don't wanna be using--
How's he gonna survive?
Or the computer because it just feels,
it doesn't feel natural enough, right.
So I got my journal and
I was starting to write
and just kind of making some observations.
Dear journal, day one.
Quick review, I'll give a quick
review of the rooftop tent
and then we'll take a little
break and we'll come back
and I'll tell you about the first morning
and how that kind of set the stage.
Rooftop tent, definitely an improvement
over a regular tent, in
terms of like sleep quality.
And also just like feeling of safety.
Like you're on top of this
car and there's a ladder.
I mean, I guess like a bear
could climb a ladder but.
You just feel like, you
feel a little bit safer
and you're literally elevated.
In the circus they do a lot of things.
They gotta be trained to do a ladder,
I think they do a tree naturally
but you gotta train 'em for a ladder.
It's quick, you open that thing up.
It's not as quick as I wanted it to be.
So it's actually pretty quick to set up.
'Cause you've got this big
leather cover basically,
rubber slash leather, whatever it is,
and it's completely
zipped around three edges
and you have to unzip it, fold it down.
Then you got to open it up,
stick the ladder in there.
And then you gotta, if
you want like airflow,
which the first night it was kind of hot,
you gotta like put these supports,
like these metal supports that
go into the side of the thing
and then they kind of like
make the awnings taught.
And I was like, I think this
took as long as a regular tent.
Like I think that the
way they make tents now,
which are like, blurp,
and they're basically up,
I think this didn't take any less time.
But there's a mattress on
the whole bottom of it.
There's a mattress on the bottom of it,
plus I added an air mattress
on top of that mattress.
That's stored in there
or are you added it?
Yeah, I mean you leave it in there
and it's a self-inflating mattress
and then I just kind of
deflate it every morning
and then just fold it back
up in the tent, no problem.
But definitely, I mean, I
definitely recommend that.
But you gotta get it level.
And like I was saying,
I took those RV blocks and made sure
it got level every single night.
Did you have a level?
I thought about it.
Like a bubble level?
I just used my intuition.
Does this feel level,
does this look level?
Is this level?
And it ended up being level, by that.
Am I self-inflating?
I overinflated the first night.
You don't wanna over inflate.
I wanted it to be hard
because when you get an
air mattress that's soft
and you wake up in the middle night
and your booty or your hip bone
is like touching the bottom.
You went too hard yet then.
I went too hard.
I was like, man, I didn't
think I could go this hard,
but I went way too hard and overinflated.
But I pretty much got
it right the second day.
Okay, I'll get into talking about--
You didn't get scared that night?
Didn't get scared that first night, again,
because I kind of knew that
there was somebody close by,
there was a person close by
and I want to talk about that.
Okay.
In a little bit about why is it
that that brings so much comfort.
But first, let's talk
about these mugs here.
Mythical.com has everything you could want
that has anything to do with us and you,
because that's what this is about.
It's about you and me and
him having the same stuff.
You wanna drink like us?
Having the same stuff.
Then drink out of this.
It's a Good Mythical Morning mug,
there's different, there's a third color.
Yeah, there's a third
color that's blue I believe
that we don't even have right
now, but you could have it.
You could be drinking out of your blue mug
while we drink out of our
green and orange mugs.
Connect with us.
We'd be a trilogy.
It makes you feel like
we're just over the ridge.
You can't see us but if
we cranked up our car,
you could hear us.
Right.
If we slurped on our mugs.
I wasn't that close, slurping
woulda not come through.
You would have felt it.
It would have to have been like a slurp
and a choke and a cough.
Only if you also own one of these.
You have to slurp, choke, and cough
and then I would be able to hear you.
Mythical.com
Almost dropped it.
Okay, so first morning,
again, I wake up and I'm like,
I don't know exactly
where I'm gonna go tonight
because of the spring
that I had designated
as my potential first
stop for a hot spring
is in the national forest,
is deep in the Inyo national
forest, which is closed.
So I mean, are they really enforcing this?
Like, what, am I gonna get fined
or am I gonna get arrested,
what is it stake here?
But I was like, you know what.
It's not the right thing to do.
Let's set that aside right now
and I'm just going to sit
here and I'll tell you,
the most wonderful moments
for me on this trip
was waking up, and first of
all, waking up pretty early
because I went to bed early.
Like you get out there, especially
when you're by yourself.
I mean, it gets dark and
you're kind of like, well,
I guess I'll go to sleep, you know?
It's like, you're just like
a farmer in the old days.
It's like every human before electricity.
You get dark and you're like,
well, what do you do now, George?
You go to sleep!
Did you have the stars
like I was talking about?
Oh yeah.
You told me you got a
special star gazing tent,
I mean seat.
I did.
That was the main thing that I said.
I told Christie, I was
like, we've gotta invest
in some camp chairs
that are actually good.
Because those like, those cheap ones
that you get from Dick's Sporting Goods
and they just wrap up, they're
the worst for your posture.
And you definitely can't see the stars.
Let me tell you about
these anti-gravity chairs,
as they call it.
It's fricking huge.
And I was like, I could
take this by myself,
but I couldn't take another person.
It couldn't take two of these.
You couldn't take, oh gosh.
It was by far, it was the
biggest thing in my truck
was that damn chair.
I had convinced myself
that it was worth it.
I think it might be and
I'll talk about that
because I think night four
is when I really used it to full effect
to try to connect with aliens.
Go ahead.
But that first morning, had
my breakfast, got my coffee.
That Starbucks instant coffee.
The Via.
I mean, I tell ya, it's good, man.
We got some of that.
You don't even really know
that you're drinking instant coffee.
Yeah, it's good.
So I'm having a little coffee
and then I'm full, you know,
I'm full in my belly.
And again, I go back to the
journal and I just start,
again, I'm not going to talk about
what I was thinking about,
but again, my theme,
my goal on the trip was
to be like water, right?
To go with the flow, to let go,
to not be this guy that
has to like analyze
and differentiate and categorize
and analyze every single
thing that encountering
and know exactly where I'm gonna go.
It was, be like water, you know,
you face an obstacle and
you, you just go around it.
That's the sound of water.
Yeah.
I feel that.
I had this really intense
sort of sense that that was happening
even that first morning,
like it was pretty powerful.
'Cause you gave yourself permission
to not just get on with anything.
It wasn't about getting to the next thing.
Yeah, you sat there and like,
I have space right here right now.
But the whole time,
and this was a challenge
throughout the whole trip.
When you're somebody who's not like water
but you're trying to be like water
the consistent challenge
when every single,
every single aspect of your
trip is TBD every single day.
Am I gonna run out of gas,
am I gonna get a flat tire?
Am I gonna really be
able to change the tire?
You know, like, am I gonna be
out of service, am I gonna?
When I get to this hot spring,
are there gonna be people there,
are they gonna have COVID?
You know, and this is how my brain works.
I'm actually considerably more anxious
than I ever realized or even
sort of put off to people,
you know what I mean?
I'm constantly in the future,
I'm constantly thinking about
all possible options,
decisions that can be made.
And the whole point of the
trip was to just be present.
The first thing that
I wrote in my journal,
which I just did digitally.
You know, some people, whatever it takes.
On the first night--
You probably didn't get hand cramps.
First night, the thing that I wrote down,
it might've been the only
thing I wrote down was,
it is hard not to think about the future
because even five minutes
from now is the future.
So including that, I just,
that was the first thing I
was over overwhelmed with.
The first thought was,
it's really hard to not
think about the future.
I was, and exactly for that reason,
because we were in control of our trips
and there's always a decision to be made
and you can make a better
decision if you anticipate,
or if you have a plan or
even if you're letting go of,
of checking certain boxes
or achieving something
or realizing the perfect trip
that you've visualized
in your mind, you know.
Even if you let go of all that,
your mind still goes to
something else and it's,
for me too, it was in the future.
Maybe for some people it's in the past
if they're dealing with
something, but for,
we're very alike in that way.
Yeah, so that was a constant challenge,
but it also was very evident to me
'cause I started thinking things like,
maybe next time I'll just go to a cabin.
I'll just drive to a cabin
and I'll be in the same
place the whole time.
But then it was like,
no, no, no, no, no, no,
don't lose the opportunity here.
It's just starting.
The opportunity is to
embrace the fact that you don't know
where you're gonna sleep.
Like that's why you're here, man.
That's how you get out of the future
and get into the present,
is by actually being faced with--
The feeling of not knowing
and not going to know.
So one of the first unknowns was,
okay, if I can't go to this hot spring
that I wanted to go to, where can I go?
Because there's another
one that I could go to,
but I've already been told
basically by the internet
that it's gonna be busy,
there's gonna be people there.
But I was like, screw it,
I mean, it's a hot spring,
let's just go check it out.
So I went to this hot spring.
I'm not gonna name the names
because I can't remember all the names
and also the whole problem is
that too many people know about 'em.
So I'm not gonna talk about where I was.
Fine, tell me later.
So I go to this hot
spring that is, you know,
north of the Alabama Hills in California,
I know it's confusing,
but you can hang on.
And it's in the middle of a giant, like
there's just so many just open valleys
that are just filled with grazing cattle.
Like, it's just throughout
all of California
and all of Nevada it's
just a bunch of cattle
grazing in the middle of
nowhere, is what it seems like.
Way more cattle than people
as far as I can tell.
And there's a hot spring
out in the middle of this cow field,
like there's like a
walkway that they've built
over the cow pasture to kind of keep you
from like walking
through cow crap and mud.
And then it just comes to this spring
in the middle of the field.
And there's literally like
cow shit around the spring
and also cows like looking
at you as you're bathing.
Well, did they get in it?
The cows don't, it's too hot for the cows.
So there's two springs.
One is the one that obviously is preferred
because there's like nine people in it.
And there's no room for another person.
I mean, maybe I could get
awkward and get in there
but again, I'm thinking about COVID
and nobody's got a mask on.
It's dirt, this is a natural spring.
This is natural.
'Cause most of the ones
that we've both experienced
before now have been--
Like a tub.
Cement lined.
Well, they'll redirect the
water into a tub or a pool.
But this was natural.
But I see that there's like
another thing down there
that's even more,
I think it actually the
one that everybody was in,
they may have reinforced it with rocks,
but the other one is just like,
the cow pasture just kind of opens up
and it's like a foot and a half of water,
but it's like 20 feet across.
And there was just one
woman laying in there
and it was so shallow that like,
she's kind of laying against the side
and like most of her
body is out of the water,
but she's still in the water.
I'm like, well, I'm gonna do what she does
and I was like, hey.
Was she naked?
No, nobody's naked, she
was fully bathing suited.
Okay.
And I sit down and I'm
like, this is pretty nice.
Like I'm sitting in
this 18 inches of water,
you know, my legs are under the water
and maybe up to my belly button
and then the rest of me is out
and then I'm kind of
like laying up against
the side of the thing on the
grass and it's pretty hot.
And it's also pretty
hot inside the spring,
it's hot outside and inside.
But I'm like, this is cool,
this is not me connecting with anything,
this is me thinking about
this woman that's across,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, not being able to
disconnect from the reality
that there's another person here and like,
am I sitting in a weird way?
You know, like just being self
conscious in general, right?
Yeah.
But also thinking about how
these people over in this
other hot tub are really loud
and like laughing and
it's kind of boisterous.
And then all of a sudden
like, oh crap, here they come.
Three or four families
come over the horizon
and they descend on
this spring that I'm in.
And like there's kids
saying like, mom, it stinks!
Like one kid's like going like, , gagging
because of the sulfur, yeah.
And then everybody's like
it's pretty hot, is it hot?
How hot is it, is it
clean, it's pretty clean!
Like, this is not enjoyable.
And they all kind of just
sort of descend on this area
and then I can just kind of get up.
I'm like, I don't want this.
Yeah.
I get up and I begin to walk over to--
Funny thing is, they
didn't want it either.
Yeah, but just like water, you
present me with an obstacle
and instead of trying to go through it
I just go around it.
and I go over to the other,
I start walking towards the hot spring
and all those other people
are, turns out, leaving.
And there's just one dude in there
and I just go and get into the spring.
First of all, it's like three feet deep,
it's deep enough to sit down.
But he's, the guy says, what's up, duder.
What's up, duder.
Duder.
Yeah, you add the R on the end of dude
and you're not conversation material.
And then the woman who was
on the other side walks over
and he's like, hey babe.
And then I'm like, oh, they're a couple.
They're a couple.
They're a married couple.
And boy, let me tell ya,
I know everything there
is to know about them
because he would not stop talking.
He was one of those guys who
is just constantly saying things,
but not necessarily anything
that you need to hear.
Oh no.
Talking a lot and saying nothing,
you know what I'm saying?
Which is why she was all alone over there
in two inches of water.
Nice guys, making conversation
but not the vibe that I'm after, you know?
And I'm not talkative in those situations.
I'm more like, right, yeah, uh huh, yeah.
You were givin' all
the signals to shut up.
But I knew it was pointless.
So I was like, Oh, and then eventually
they were like, duder, we gotta leave?
They had to go on.
And I did get some time to myself in this,
but again, you know, there's
like a family over there
and I was just like, isn't
what I wanted it to be,
but I need to just embrace,
I need to embrace what it is.
But then I was like, okay,
all right, let's leave.
Let's go to the next place.
And I was like, I'm just
gonna kind of just go
and just see where I feel
led to stop and camp.
Because with this rig I can
basically just go off and go.
There's all these dirt roads
off the side of the road, the whole way.
And it's all public land,
you can just go find a spot.
So I drive off, I drive up into,
I get to a place I'm like,
this is a cool like forest.
This isn't a desert,
this is more like forest.
I like forest, I'll drive into forest.
Would you?
So I drove into the forest
and started seeing like campsites,
the road started getting
rougher and I was like,
I would not be able to do this
without a four wheel drive vehicle.
Drove around, found a couple of spots.
And then eventually kind
of settle in a place.
And first of all I was like,
I haven't really seen any fires yet.
Like, I'm not really close to the fires,
but haven't really
experienced a lot of smoke.
But at that moment a wall of smoke
began to like roll through the forest.
Really?
And I was like, oh, I'm at the perimeter
of the smoke cloud.
Either that or you're at a fire.
No, but I was looking on the map
and I knew that I wasn't
near an actual fire.
This was smoke coming from the fire
that's in the Inyo national
forest but not where I was.
And it wasn't one of these
situations where like,
it smells like a campfire.
It was like, no, I am in a campfire.
Like I cannot breathe normally,
everything began to smell like smoke.
I'm breathing in smoke and
I know that's not healthy.
So I'm like, okay, the universe
is telling me to move on.
Flow right to the next place.
You're doing it different than me.
I'm gonna start doing it your way.
It's not in the lips, it's in the mouth.
And so I go to the next thing
and I actually ended up crossing over,
into Nevada, not like, you
thought I was gonna cross over
into the supernatural realm,
but no, just into Nevada.
To the smoke monster.
And started working my way
towards another hot spring.
And this is, again, this is one
that's relatively popular on the internet.
So I was like, well, we'll see.
But it's starting to get
dark so I had to find a spot.
And I get to this spring and
you can't camp next to the spring.
I mean, this is one that has
a parking lot, it's popular.
And then outside of the parking lot,
like half a mile from the entrance,
there's a bunch of places to camp.
And I kind of drove over a hill
and found a place that I
couldn't see anybody else
and I was like, all right,
I'm gonna set up shop here.
But I'm like a mile walk at
this point from the spring.
But I'm like, you know what?
I'm gonna wait until it gets dark
and I'm gonna walk to
the spring and enjoy it.
Of course, this is not an original idea,
everyone's thinking the
same thing, apparently.
So I walked to the spring and
yes, it is filled with people.
Jumping.
But this spring,
most of the springs have
like the hot water source
coming into them and then there's a pool
and then like an overflow to a second pool
and overflow to a third pool,
each pool getting cooler.
The first pool, which is the
one you want to be in is clean
and it's not run off and
it's hot, everyone's in that.
I didn't want to get
right next to everybody
but also there was no room.
So I go to the second pool.
So the first pool has like
five dudes, middle-aged dudes.
No women.
And then the second pool
has an old man in it.
I was like, is this
old man with the dudes?
I don't think so 'cause he seems,
his energy is very different.
Was nakedness happening at this one.
No nakedness, it was also very dark,
but everybody had on trunks
as far as I could tell.
So I'm like, I'm gonna
get into this hot tub
with this old man and I walk up there,
first of all, they're like, how you doing?
Come on in, the water's fine.
No duder this time?
No duder but very much like
a lot of dad joke energy.
And this is coming from
a dad who makes jokes.
But like, not like this guy,
that I'll talk about in a second.
But the second hot tub
with the old man in it,
the old man says, this one's taken.
What?
And he's like, just kidding.
He got you, 'cause you're
you're susceptible.
Anyone says, this one's
taken, you're like,
oh, sorry, I'll go to the third one.
Oh yeah, and I'll talk
about that in a second,
hot spring etiquette.
Well, I get in with the old man now.
It's not a big, hot tub.
I mean, there's enough room
for me and this old man
and the old man is on his all fours
and like putting one leg
up in the air really high
and then bringing it down
and putting the other leg,
he's doing, what do you call it?
Calisthenics.
And then he gets on his back
and he's doing all this other stuff
and I'm like, this guy is alone.
He's not with the other guys, clearly.
This dude was a character,
he started talking about,
he liked traveled around with
that Rainbow Society thing,
you know what I'm talking about?
Like, there's a group called I don't--
A vacuum cleaner salesman?
It's like a, I think
it's some kind of cult.
They like travel around in buses.
Like a Rainbow Society or something,
I don't know what it is,
but I mean, it's like a bunch of hippies.
And he had spent some time with them.
He matches the profile.
But then dad, number one I'll call him,
this is what he would be in the script,
is sitting and the he's
the guy who's very loud.
They're drinking the Coors
Light, they're very drunk.
Oh gosh.
And the guy says, you guys
know anybody who's got COVID?
What?
You guys know, like anybody in
your inner circle got COVID?
And of course, I'm not
gonna engage with this guy
so I don't say anything and
nobody says has anything.
He's like, yeah, that's what I thought.
I mean, I think it's a conspiracy.
It's better than him saying, well, I do.
You're looking at one, I'm in your circle.
And so I'm like, is
this what hot tubs are?
Hot tubs are coming down
and sharing your space
with a very flexible old man,
by the way, very flexible,
very flexible hippie.
The heat just really, it makes
you ligaments just plyable.
And then a COVID denier.
And he's like, yeah, you
know hospitals get $37,000
for every COVID patient.
I mean, they're just
doing it for the money.
They're doing it for the money, yes.
And I'm just like, do I have to put,
do I have to listen to this bullshit?
Do I have to listen to it, I guess I do.
I guess I do because the water feels good.
It did feel good, didn't it?
And I was not in a--
How hot was it?
I could tell that the main,
based on the temperature of the second tub
the main tub would have
been hotter than a hot tub.
Like 110?
No, probably 120.
Oh.
Like, could scald yourself
if you're not careful.
Like you can't go in up to
your neck and just stay there
unless you just really are going for it.
But they can take it
and they can reroute it
so it cools down a little bit.
Anyway, I was like, I'm not
in a, 'cause you know me,
I've got the tendency to be like,
well, let me tell you
why it's not a conspiracy
and you're full of crap.
Let's, you know, but I
don't typically do that with
strangers.
Strangers.
So, but I was like,
I'm definitely not gonna
say anything to this guy.
He's not interested in the truth anyway.
So I kind of stick around for a little bit
and then I kind of walked
the mile back to my campsite.
And as I was walking
back, I was just like,
I don't know, I don't
know about hot Springs.
It's like, am I gonna find
one that I can have to myself?
Now, bear in mind that the next morning
I had my time, my coffee,
I'm listening to multiple books
as I travel these distances
and some of those books are really,
I'll talk about one of 'em,
one of the ones that was
more of the fun listens,
I listened to like three
books throughout the trip.
But I'm listening to ones
that are a little bit more serious,
a little bit more about spiritual things,
contemplative things and again,
I'm still having a really
good time in my soul.
But the expectation of what hot Springs,
I mean, I'm beginning to
think that this is a lesson
that I'm being taught a lesson that like
you're going around looking
for these hot springs,
that ain't where it's at,
you're not gonna find what you want.
You cannot place this
expectation on these hot springs
'cause there's gonna be
old, flexible old men
and COVID deniers and et cetera, you know.
But I head onto the next one.
Again, my destination is determined by
where the next hot spring is.
So I get to one that is supposed
to be one of the best ones
and I get to it and I'm like, is that it?
It's a cow tub, it's like something
you would put feed or water
in for cows, like a circle.
A metal tub, something we
would get to like bathe in
on the show but much bigger.
And dirty.
And of course the water kind of stinks
'cause it's like sulfur and
I kind of parked next to it
and I realized there's all these people,
there are all these campsites that,
we all have a line of sight
to the spring and I'm like,
maybe it's just bad etiquette
to like park right next to the spring
because they're all saying,
we all use the spring,
you can't just like set your campsite out
right next to the spring even
though there's a fire ring.
I didn't really know the etiquette.
But I did, as I looked around,
had my first encounter
with full nakedness.
There we go.
But I'm also thinking like,
they're gonna come to this cow tub.
I'm gonna be here.
Question mark?
And then I'm like, listen and not to,
I have a hot tub at home, okay.
It took you three days to
come to that realization.
You went all the way across the country
looking for something
that you had at home.
Ooh, that.
That's an analogy that I'll
talk about in a little bit,
but I have a hot tub at
home that is, A, clean,
B, I can dial in the
temperature on my phone.
Yeah, yeah.
C, I determine who goes in it.
Right, and how much clothes they have on.
Right, these people that I
choose, it's my property.
Yeah, you're the king of the castle.
No cows, no algae, it
doesn't smell like sulfur,
it's filtered, it's right out my backyard.
Now I know that's a
privileged thing to have,
to be able to have a
hot tub at your house.
I'm blessed, I'm privileged.
But I also am looking for hot
tubs throughout the nation.
Yeah.
Hot springs.
And I got a hot tub at home.
This is interesting, yes.
That's better, and it
hit me at that point.
So I was like, you know what I'm gonna do?
Sounds like an opportunity to journal.
You know what I'm gonna
do, I'm gonna bypass this,
I'm gonna get back in my truck
and I'm just gonna go up into the woods
and find a parking space, a camping space
because the thing that I'm after
is solitude and reflection,
and contemplation.
Yes, there you go!
I go up way into the woods,
to the point where I'm like,
there's only one way outta here,
what if there's a forest fire here, right?
But I'm like, screw it.
Or a dude with photos, I don't know.
I'm setting up here.
Who knew what you had to fear.
And this was the first night
that I set up in a place where,
I had my map and I've
gotten, I had no service
but I've got my satellite phone deal.
So I'm still safe and
connected in some way.
And I know where I'm at,
I can get out of here.
But this is when as it's
starting to get dark,
I start to think about bears,
mountain lions, killers, you know?
Funny thing is, I didn't
think about any of that
until I met one.
Well, okay.
But I wasn't alone, you know,
I think that makes a big difference.
And it gets to the
point where it gets dark
and your eyes adjust to the light
in your immediate vicinity,
and it was a new moon.
So the Moonlight on our trip,
and you probably noticed this,
this star light was
incredible, there was no moon.
There was very little moon.
I think the beginning of
the trip was the new moon.
It was up during the day,
but then it set before night.
So no moonlight so when it gets dark
you've got your little lantern
there and your headlamp,
you can't see anything and it's just
every direction is just pitch black.
And what could be in that dark
really started to kind of freak me out.
And I told the story a long time ago
about the time I went down
to like burn some stuff
when I was working for my father in law.
In the woods, yeah.
Yeah, and we were like burning,
it was back when they had to
keep everybody's, you know.
Medical records.
You had to keep everybody's
records as paper.
And then I think it was just
like old patients who had left
or had died or whatever
and so you could shred 'em
or you could just burn them or whatever.
I don't know exactly how
it works 20 years ago.
But I would be out there burning and then,
and I had recently watched "The Ring"
and so I think that the
little girl from "The Ring"
is gonna like come up out of nowhere
and I started getting
this image in my mind.
Well, one of the reasons
that in The Lost Causes
of Bleak Creek that the,
not villain, if you will,
but like one of the scary things in there
is, spoiler alert, the little girl, Ruby.
'Cause the idea of a little
girl that's sorta got something
demonic inside her is the thing
that is one of the most
scary things for me
and when I get out there alone.
You think about her?
I begin think that like,
I'm gonna turn around
and there's gonna be like
a little possessed girl
like on all fours turned over backwards
like crab crawling at me, like.
And then the moment I
think about it I'm like,
you're an idiot, you're a 42 year old man
out here scared of the dark
and you're thinking about
things you've seen in horror movies.
Yeah, yeah.
And then I like laugh
it off and then I like,
you know, start like making
my dinner and then I'm like.
Looking over your shoulder!
I turn around, yeah, I
hear something and like,
is she here now?
Wow.
And, and then I'm like, man, this is,
if I knew that there was
somebody 100 yards away,
I wouldn't be thinking about this.
Like just the proximity to another person.
And I was like, isn't that,
I was like, what does that say about me?
That I want to be isolated,
but I want to know where other people are.
And when I don't know how
far I am from other people
I began to imagine that
there's possessed people
who are close.
It's like, what's going on with me?
So eventually after it gets too dark
I get up in my tent and I go to sleep.
But then that morning I woke
up and again, same thing,
once the morning comes the
little girl can't come.
It's how physics works.
She hates it, she's down in the well.
She's all, I cannot
come out into the light.
So I drove, so I had a nice morning,
I drove down, I drove to a cave
that had pictographs from
thousands of years ago.
Wow.
And it also had metal bars
that they had put on the
full face of the cave.
So you can't get in
there and screw 'em up.
'Cause people.
Why people gotta be like that?
Why can't you just not
screw with the pictographs?
Why you gotta put metal
gates on the front of it?
Because even the most well meaning people
are gonna touch it.
They're gonna just reach
out and touch it and rub it
before they've thought about
if they should do that or not.
You rub a pictograph
for thousands of years,
it's just a rock.
Yeah, but it was pretty cool,
took some pictures of that.
Write that in your journal.
Toquima Cave, I think it's called.
That sounds right.
I mean, I took pictures and I was like,
man, why were they trying to say.
It looks like just circles and lines.
Maybe they were just like,
let's draw circles and lines.
Yeah.
Probably.
Or maybe this is like representative
of some sort of contact
they made with aliens,
which I'm gonna try to do tonight.
I mean, it could have
been a football coach,
like doing the offensive play.
Ancient football.
So then, again I've got, the cool thing is
is I've got this, I've
got my app, the Gaia app
and I've pre downloaded
all the maps for this area,
for all the places I'm gonna go.
And it's got layers
that you could turn on.
Like, this is a US forest service,
this is the topography, whatever.
Possessed girl layer.
This is your cell phone service coverage.
Like you can see
where you're gonna get into
cell phone service by carrier.
I needed that.
So, super easy, and then you can download
all the maps at anytime, anyway.
So I saw that there was a ghost town
down, like an hour down.
I mean, it's only like 15 miles away
but because of the crazy roads and stuff,
it would take me an hour to get there,
but a ghost town that had a hot spring.
Oh.
And I'm like, okay, all
right, this sounds fine.
Double cool.
So there's this part of
Nevada near that Toquima Cave.
I know where duder's going now.
There's these sort of the hills
that have all the trees on them
that are like conifer trees of some kind,
like, you know, some kind of pine tree.
And it's really awesome
because they're like not
super thick and they just have
this sort of like
fairytale quality to them.
But then when you get to the base of them
it just turns into just field,
and there's usually cattle
and the people have made
ranches out of all this stuff.
But dirt roads would just go forever.
And so I go down this dirt road
and I get to a place called
Pots Ranch, I think it was.
And it's just an old house, an
old farmhouse and like a barn
that looked like they'd been abandoned
for many, many generations.
That's cool.
Or many, many decades.
But probably been around since like,
you know, 1800s or whatever.
Could you walk through it?
Yeah, I took some pictures
and walked in a little bit,
but it was like the
floor was falling apart.
I'll share some of those pictures.
I bet you weren't thinking,
I'm gonna camp here tonight.
No, 'cause I wasn't far enough,
I hadn't moved far enough.
I needed to keep moving
in order to kind of get back to a place
where I could be close to
home by the end of the trip.
And this is, and I'm almost at
my furthest point away from home,
I'm kind of in the middle
of Nevada at this point.
But I am like, okay, but
there's a hot spring here.
Here's where it's at on the map
and I kind of went past the house
and went down this dirt
road and I get down
and I'm like, Oh yes,
this is gonna be awesome,
there's nobody around for miles.
And I get down there,
and I'd seen a picture
of the hot spring on the internet
'cause I had service for a second.
And it was the same deal,
it was like, there's a creek
and they they've run the Creek
through a pipe into a tub.
I get down there, the tub's gone.
The pipe literally just is there
and just goes onto the ground.
They've removed the tub.
The tub, a ghost.
There's just a little pool there
that they've kind of dammed up
that's about six inches deep.
So I just like sat there
and stuck my feet in there.
Like a poor little boy.
It felt great, but I was like,
how would this be if the tub was here?
why you gotta take the tub!
You should've brought your own tub.
Next time, man.
I thought about it, I was like,
could you have a baby
pool that you inflate?
Like a mobile hot tub?
It's gotta be like made a Kevlar.
They make those for like
really rambunctious children.
I did have my first shower there.
I had been in a couple of hot tubs,
but I had my solar shower,
like heated the water up with the sun.
You talking about a SAC with
a tube coming out of it?
Yeah, basically, solar showers
sounds more sophisticated.
I shower myself, I use
soap, I wash my parts.
It feels good, doesn't it?
It feels great.
If you haven't washed
your parts in a few days.
You gotta wash your parts.
And I had a, I was naked
in the middle of a field.
Yeah, that's nice.
With mountains on both sides
and just valley as far
as I could see both ways.
And I was like, this is pretty awesome.
I mean, I wish that the tub was here,
but this is pretty awesome.
And I began, it's funny,
the moment that my whole
perspective began to shift
from like, are you
learning your lesson yet?
You come with these expectations.
Drop your expectations, man.
That's the whole point of this,
you gotta drop the expectations.
The tub may not be
there, it doesn't matter.
Take a shower, wash your parts.
It's not something you
can just reflect on.
The way you say it it
does seem like it's like,
I should've known this, I
should've just realized this.
You have to experience it.
But actually, I think that,
that's the thing that I'm learning
and what I was saying in
the last one too, was like,
it made sense when people talked about
connecting with nature
or connecting with themselves in nature,
connecting with God in nature,
you know, whatever your
intention is, it makes sense.
But it's different to
actually experience it.
And I think, I guess that's
true for just lessons in life
is that like, the
strongest lessons you learn
are the ones that you experience.
And which is comforting as a parent,
and you to think about it
in terms of your kids too,
that like you can't protect
them from everything.
And it's like, that's
the most powerful way
to change who you are as a
person is to go through things.
And so, but maybe I'm hearing
too much in what you're saying
that it almost feels like,
I had to go through this
in order to learn it.
But it's like, I went through this
and I was able to learn it.
That's very much what was happening.
I had my therapy appointment last night
to kind of follow up from my trip.
And of course I ended
up sharing everything
that happened to me internally.
Which even that morning
when I'm taking my shower
and sitting next to this
hot creek and stuff,
there was a lot of things that
I was just sort of realizing
and more than just the surface level of,
this trip represents my
life in a lot of ways
and the way that I live
and the things that I seek.
It's not just something
you can write down.
It's not something that
just happens in your brain,
is what I think we're saying.
Yeah, and that was a big,
I'll share a little bit of
that because I think that was
one of the biggest realizations
on the trip is that I,
you know, I've talked
about how I live in my mind
and I'm a victim of my thoughts,
which is a very normal thing,
but that, you know, heart
knowledge, experiencing things,
something just being true because it is,
not because you can
rationalize it, explain it,
analyze it, break it down, and
present it to someone else.
But something that you can just experience
and sort of know intrinsically,
like access inside yourself.
Was something that was just
very visceral and very powerful
that was continuing to
happen throughout the trip.
But that day now, you know
I brought the special chair.
I had intentions to try
to connect with aliens.
Now, the thing I didn't talk about
as I had listened to the
30 minute guided meditation
from Dr. Steven Greer in
the CE5, I think it is app.
Again, this is from
that Netflix documentary
which I was fascinated by.
Again, I don't believe it, I don't--
"Close Enounters of the Fifth
Kind", is what it's called.
And basically the fifth kind
representing essentially
a cosmic connection to aliens.
Not like just seeing them physically, but.
Receiving a signal from them.
It's based on the fact
that if there is something
to the idea of a collective
consciousness of the universe
then other intelligent life
out there is a part of that.
And we can, if we get into that sort of,
what do you want to call it,
metaphysical, spiritual plane
there is some way to have a connection.
Now, again, the rational part of my brain
which is very dominant in
my mind, in my personality,
is like, this is almost bullshit, right?
Like, I would be flummoxed if
this were to be true, right?
If you really could connect
with aliens in this way.
But also, why the hell not try?
Who am I going to hurt if I try?
And wouldn't it be cool
if it could happen?
So tonight I'm gonna try.
'Cause I finally listened to like
the way he kind of talks
about the meditation process
and how you're supposed to like basically
broadcast where you're
at so they'll find you.
Oh, right.
But I see this hot spring on the map
that I'm not too far from and I'm like,
well, let's go there,
maybe there'll be a tub.
And it was funny,
the moment that my expectations
completely evaporated
is the moment that I found the
best hot spring experience.
This is the next to last night.
I stop at a place
that I'm not going to
tell you where it's at
because I hope to return to it.
But I go there and there
is two large families
with two large trailers
who are camped right next to the spring.
And I'm like, ah, crap.
And they're getting out of the spring
like they've been bathing,
like they've taken a
little break or whatever.
And I kind of just drive up to the spring
'cause I'm like, I'll just, you know,
I wasn't planning on camping there.
I was like, I'm just going
to take a dip, take a soak.
And I'm like, oh, you
guys got a good spot.
And he's like, well, we're leaving.
And you're like, you do that.
And he was like, and I
just cleaned the hot tub.
So basically it was a
heart shaped stone tub.
That the way it works is, again,
they all work the same way,
you've got the hot water
source from the spring
that somebody has piped into this thing.
It fills up and then it kind
of goes out over a spillway
but there's a plug in the
bottom of a lot of these
that you can pull, so it'll drain it
and then you can scrub it.
And the dude, because they
had been there for a few days,
antelope hunting, didn't know
that was something that happened,
they had two antelopes already.
Like draped over their
trailers or something?
Butchered or something?
I didn't see 'em, he just
said, we've killed two.
Huh?
He drained and scrubbed the thing.
He had drained and scrubbed it
and he had just filled it up
and he like showed me how it worked.
That's cool.
And then they left and I was like.
Oh yes.
Am I about to have a heart
shaped tub all to myself?
No, I'm not.
Oh.
Because, now this is like two o'clock,
I was like, there's no way
no one's gonna show up.
But I was like, you know
what, I'm gonna stay here,
I'm gonna camp here.
So I go ahead and I take my
rooftop tent out, I set it up.
I'm probably, I don't
know what the etiquette is
but I'm probably closer to the
hot spring than I should be.
But I was like, I wanna get in it.
Not that nobody else was gonna get in it
but I'm probably 100 feet from
it, so it was pretty close.
And then up rolls two cars,
two older couples get out
and they walk up to me and they're like,
so, is that the spring?
And then it hits me, I'm like,
they think I'm an authority.
Yes.
Because I'm here and because
I'm close to the spring
they assume that I have some sort of
intrinsic authority here.
This is how people's brains work.
You can use it against them.
And I was like--
You could say no.
Yeah, it's just been cleaned.
Oh no.
Shoulda said it's dirty.
No, no, no.
I played it like this.
I'm gonna be generous with this spring.
Okay.
I'm the keeper of the spring,
That's what these people
believe, I'm gonna be generous.
And I said, it's just been cleaned,
it should be warmed up for ya.
And that, and they're like,
well, we're just gonna
stay for a little bit.
I mean, if you don't mind.
I was like, this is working.
And I'm like, take all the time you want.
As if I have any authority at all,
but I'm just going with it
'cause they seem to be going with it.
Okay.
But you coulda also tell
'em, take 10 minutes.
No, 'cause if you give somebody a limit
they naturally want to exceed it.
Don't give 'em a limit, just be generous.
Be nice and then they're
like, I'ma give him his space.
He lives here, look at his beard.
They were from Ohio.
I said, you know, Chuck Testa?
And they were like, oh
yeah, the commercial.
I was like, I made that commercial.
Really?
And boy, that got me some brownie points.
Seriously?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're like, he keeps the
spring and he makes commercials.
How does he do it all?
'Cause that is all.
And so I talked to them for a while.
You were in the spring?
No, no, no.
You were standing over it keeping it.
I was sitting in my alien
chair next to my truck,
on this side where you had to walk past me
to get to the spring.
That couple ended up leaving,
another couple showed up,
a younger couple.
That was the #vanlife couple
where they were taking the pictures
that I told you about during your story.
Yeah, priorities out of whack.
They ended up being really cool.
They stayed the night and an
older man stayed the night.
Now, not really close to me
and the way it ends up working
is you ended up spending,
you can spend about 10 or 15 minutes
in a really hot, hot tub.
This one, the temperature
of the water was 130 degrees
coming out of the pipe so
you'd have to like, fill it up
and then divert it or put
a restrictor in the pipe.
The engineering behind
these things is pretty cool.
Put a restrictor in it
so it's not quite filling up fast enough
and it slowly losing temperature
so it probably gets down to like 110.
And so that night I just got
into the hot tub by myself
for 20, 30 minutes, looked at the stars.
Everyone was completely
quiet, they were both gone,
they were in their van and
in their camper asleep,
not talking, and I'm just
out there and I'm like,
man, this is awesome, I get it.
Like, I'm in this heart shaped hot tub.
And then it hit me like, oh,
I need to reach out to the aliens.
Yeah.
So I began the meditative process,
I went through the steps,
which ended with me.
I'm in the heart shaped hot tub.
You know the one.
Oh yeah, 'cause you start.
You start with a galaxy, you
move to the solar system.
You funnel your signal down.
You move to the North America,
you move into America,
you move to Nevada, bomba,
bomba, bomba down to there.
And let me tell you.
That was the moment, right?
You're like, I'm right here.
I'm here, I'm like, you can't miss me.
Heart shaped hot tub.
And the thing I can see
most closely relate it to
is the time I tried to speak
in tongues in New York.
When I was trying to share the gospel
with the man on the bench
who couldn't speak English.
And I was like, Lord, this is when,
this is when I speak
in tongues, this is it.
And I was like, almost,
going to open my mouth
and just see what happens, you know.
Because I was under the understanding
that speaking in tongues was
sort of angelic purposes,
not for the edification of the body.
That's the theological stuff
that no one cares about
unless you're one of those
people who cares about it.
Anyway,
they didn't come, they didn't show up.
I did it twice.
And I was so, I was so committed.
I was like, I am willing to believe this.
Like, if you just show
up, I am here, I am ready.
There's also other people
here, but they're sleeping.
It didn't happen, it didn't happen.
I'm not saying I'll never try again,
but I tried so hard that night.
I can't imagine trying harder,
but Dr. Steven Greer
suggest doing it in a group.
They were there.
You were in the leadership position.
You have to have
commitment from everybody.
I think you gotta have buy in,
that would have been a lot to ask.
I was gonna say sorry,
but you know what, water.
I was fine, I was like,
I wasn't supposed to meet
the aliens on this trip.
Now I know I'm getting a little bit long,
there's something significant
I gotta talk about.
Sure.
Before the last night,
I'm like, okay, I gotta
find a place to stop here.
I was kind of doing the game
that you were doing which is,
I want to get kind of close to Vegas
'cause that's gonna be close to home,
that's like four hours from home.
But it's hot down there
so where am I gonna go?
So I stopped about an
hour outside of Vegas,
north of Vegas in some sort
of higher mountainy areas.
It's still kind of deserty,
but about 10 degrees cooler
because of the elevation.
And as I was looking for my
campsite, I passed by this sign,
It said, Trilobite Fossil Area.
Oh.
And I was like, oh wow.
I've always wanted to find a
fossil, it's one of my dreams.
I've never found one, I've
searched the world over.
Well, I've looked on the
side of the road a few times.
So I'm like, well, let
me find my campsite first
and then I'll come back to this area
because I want to kind of
know where I'm gonna sleep.
10 minutes down the road I find a spot
way down in this dirt road
next to this pile of rocks
where I did end up camping.
But I go back to the
Trilobite Fossil Area.
You park your car and
you walk up this path.
And I like hear a kid's voice
and I hadn't seen another car
and it felt like I was
in the middle of nowhere
so I was like, oh, is that the aliens here
in the form of a child?
They have kids too.
It was just a family, a human family.
And they were getting the fossils.
There's the shale deposit out there
where there's this millions,
you know of, trilobites,
mostly just heads and some full bodies.
Really?
I didn't see any of 'em yet.
But like it's this shale,
it's these very flat
rocks that you pick up.
And I was like, what do you do, just,
I start talking to the family,
I'm like, you just turn rocks over?
And they're like, well
actually we have a hammer
and you have to hit the
rocks and they'll split
and then you see if
there's fossils in there.
I'm like, ah, I've got an axe
in my truck, I'll go get it.
It's like, as I said it, I was like,
I'm going to kill you is what they heard.
Yes.
That way you don't run when
I come at you with an axe.
I'm going to get my axe, family.
So I turn around, I go
to get my little axe
and I'm coming back down the path--
And they're running.
And no, I get back and
a little boy is crying.
I'm like, I'm just gonna
use it for the fossils,
I'm not gonna kill you with it.
The little boy is crying
because he's locked his keys,
his parent's keys in their car.
And they're like, can you help us?
And I'm like, oh, I don't know,
I don't really want to
help anyone right now.
I'm about to get a fossil.
I mean, I can bust your window.
It's getting dark, you know,
I'm here for my fossil.
But I'm like, sure, what happened?
They're like, he locked
the keys in the car.
Our campsite where our camper's at
is just a couple miles down
the road, could you take us?
I was like, well, I got room for one,
which sounds like something
a serial killer would say,
I realize that now, but
I only had room for one.
Did you have pictures that
you wanted them to vote on?
Because you are becoming that guy.
I showed them all my pictures.
You want to sell them.
So I took the dad and he
got the key and came back
and they were like super
appreciative, whatever.
That was my biggest fear, by the way,
I only had one key to the sprinter van.
I think it's smart enough
not to let you lock it
when the keys are in it, but
I was very anxious about that.
Yeah, I had an extra for that reason.
You rescued them.
It was a give and take.
I saved the day for them,
they would probably be dead without me.
Sure.
But the thing that they provided is--
They would have killed
the kid out of anger.
The thing that they provided
is the method how to get fossils.
I would have been out
there turning rocks over,
and let me tell you, I would
have never found anything
'cause you have to split the rocks
'cause everyone's turned the rocks over.
They had found three of these things
so I was confident that
I was gonna find one.
But I was like, it's getting dark,
but I'm going to find
my first ever fossil.
And then I began to attach
a lot of expectation to finding a fossil
and the sun was going down
and I'm frantically running
around, hitting these rocks.
And I'm like, I've never
gonna find a fossil!
I'm not a guy that finds fossils.
You're moving fast.
I'm having a little bit of a pity party.
And then I'm trying other things like,
maybe if I close my eyes and
walk and just set my hands down
I will be directed to
where the fossils are.
You were sincerely thinking that?
Oh, I did that.
If you had to watch me,
it would have been like,
I was just laying back
and then I was like,
I sense the fossil and I
would go down and touch it
and try it, and nothing.
That's like, I mean,
that's like praying to win
your recreation soccer game.
Yeah, which I also used to do.
Yeah, right.
So then I was like, okay,
well it's getting dark.
You know what, three more rocks.
And then I do three and not find one.
Okay, two more rocks.
Two more.
I kept doing that strategy
until I finally found one.
Now, I don't have it with me because,
the reason I didn't bring it
is because I'm afraid that
if I showed it to you,
you'd be like, that's a fossil?
You know what I'm saying, it's
like, it's not impressive.
It's the head of a
trilobite, it's really small,
it's very clearly a fossil
if you really look at it,
but it's not like,
this thing ain't going in the Smithsonian,
you know what I'm saying?
Like, and all the ones out there are like,
oh, I can see the outline
of where this thing died,
but it's not this even a discoloration
as much as it's an imprint
of this ancient crustacean
or whatever they are.
But it's special to you.
It's special to me
and it's sort of my, what
is the word, talisman?
Talisman.
Amulet?
For my trip, you know.
Souvenir.
Souvenir that I kind of hold on to,
the significant life things that happened
because I've got this thing to
kind of hold on to, whatever.
Keep it in your pocket at all times.
So I found that, then the
last night of camping,
camping next to a rock
pile, a big rock pile.
And in the middle of this giant valley
there's this giant rock pile,
kind of like the Joshua Tree tight rocks
but a little bit different.
And I get there as it's getting dark,
the sun has already
gone down but I'm like,
I gotta really set up really quickly.
And I like to get out
of the car and I'm like,
whoa, what was that?
A bat.
You're afraid of bats.
I hate bats, and I have
set up next to a bat cave.
Oh.
'Cause there's multiple bats
coming out of the giant rock pile.
I'm like, I set up next to a bat cave.
And I'm not Batman.
You know how they see,
they see by yelling at you.
And they're attracted to bugs
and I'm the only source
of light in this valley.
What do bugs like?
Lights.
So I'm like, well, I'm gonna see
if I can do everything in the dark.
Seriously?
I'm so afraid of bats
that I was like I'm gonna
cook my dinner in the dark.
I'm gonna do everything in the dark.
I kept lights off
and I was able to do almost
everything in the dark.
There's a few things you had
to turn the lights on for.
And at that point there
were moths coming up to me
and the bats were coming to the moths,
like, it was a little freaky.
They didn't attack me.
But I got in my tent that
night and this is where,
now I'm finally getting
to these two realizations,
one related to our conversation
and another one sort of
a larger scale thing,
but also kind of related.
2:30 in the morning.
I wake up and I'm like,
this doesn't happen to me.
I wake up in the middle of the night,
but take a wiz, back to
sleep, whatever, you know?
Yeah.
But I can't sleep and then
I could not stop thinking.
It is very weird because
it was very vivid.
I could not stop thinking about
how polarized our country is.
Like, it was very strange.
And I think it had something
to do with the fact that,
you know, I had been thinking
about these wildfires
the whole time that I'm on this trip
and I'd been trying to avoid the smoke
and I knew I was about to
go back into the smoke.
And I had been on the
internet a little bit.
Like if I had service,
I was like, checking in.
You know, there was a
few things happening.
Like a few emails or whatever
that I like looked at.
I wasn't completely disconnected,
I tried not to set some
unrealistic standard for myself,
but I was like, I'm not gonna
be on the internet very much
but if I have service,
I might check something.
And I made the mistake of going
on Twitter a couple of times
and of course, when you go to Twitter,
especially Twitter, I mean Facebook,
which I don't go to 'cause
it's even worse but,
everyone has an opinion
about these wildfires, right?
And of course I had been
around the COVID denier guy
and I was like, I'm just like,
I'm looking at what people are saying
about the wildfires
online and it's, you know,
what our president is
saying about the wildfires
and there's this narrative that,
oh, the problem with the West
coast is forest mismanagement.
Like that's what's
causing these wildfires.
It's not climate change,
climate change is a hoax.
And I'm just like, this is
so disheartening, right?
It's just so disheartening that
we're dealing with something so tragic,
that we're just beginning to deal with it.
It's gonna be just
continued further tragedy
for the coming decades.
And it is related to climate
change, but you know what,
there is also an element
of forest mismanagement
and that contributes to it, right?
It's not one or the other.
It actually, both contribute to it.
But we're so divided that--
You can't give an inch.
You have to be on one side or the other.
And if you believe that
it's forest mismanagement
you have to believe that
climate change is a hoax
even though I'm not gonna
give all the arguments
for climate change, but it's happening
and it is almost assuredly
caused by humans.
And if you're on that side of it,
then you won't listen to anybody
who's got anything to say
that's other than, this
is just climate change.
No, it has nothing to do
with forest mismanagement.
That's you, it's not California,
those are national forests.
I'm not gonna get into the details of it,
but the thing that
really just kind of like,
I could not go back to
sleep is I was like,
and it was related to some of the stuff
that I was reading about
in the way that we dig in so deeply
and identify with our position
and we think of ourselves as
Democrats and Republicans,
Christians, atheists, whatever,
and we get into our group and we just,
we put these shields around us
and those shields cannot be penetrated
by anybody else's ideas.
Yeah.
And I mean, I really think that it's,
it will be our downfall.
The problems that we face
as a species are so large
and there's so many of us
that our level of division,
it will be our downfall.
Well, that's the hopeful
conclusion I was waiting for.
Well, no, and I was just like,
wow, I can't stop thinking about this.
But related to that,
as I was driving back,
and again, this is related
to a book that I was reading
which I'm not going to talk
about what book I was reading
and that kind of made me
think about these things,
'cause maybe I'll talk about
that at a different time.
But I thought about our conversation,
the conversation that we
had about me believing
that you were as competitive as me.
Now, I'll say I have looked at
what people have said about,
a few people have talked about
what they thought about the conversation
and kind of analyzed,
thank you for those of you
who have contributed to that conversation.
I mean, I definitely got the impression
that a lot of people were like,
why did you guys end up
talking about that for an hour?
And the reason we ended up
talking about that for an hour
is because of me, because I
thought that it was gonna be,
you know, I never intended
for us to talk about,
I thought I was gonna say,
I think you're just as competitive as me
and we'd have a 10 minute
conversation about it
and it would be lighthearted
and it would end somewhere
where you'd be like, yeah, I am.
But the moment that you
were like, I don't think so.
I was like, okay, well, I do think so.
And it became this hour
long conversation about it.
And basically what I realized is that,
and this is, I mean, this is my tendency.
My tendency is to have an
opinion, have a perspective,
and then be very invested in
getting whoever I'm talking to
to agree with my perspective, right.
And one of the things that kind of clicked
based on some stuff that I was reading
is that all arguments, all debate,
all sort of obsession
with wanting to be right,
is based in an overidentification
with our mental position.
In other words, I become invested
in this opinion that I
have, which by the way,
is not even something
that I really care about.
Whether or not you're competitive
or whether or not you see
how you are as competitive
is not an important thing.
This is not something that
impacts my life, your life,
this is just a conversation,
almost a philosophical
inconsequential debate of kind.
But I was invested proving to you
that you actually think the same way I do.
And that's based in ego.
And it's based in me identifying
myself with my position,
but also ultimately, my fear of death.
And let me explain that.
Okay.
This is kind of mind blowing.
But basically, you know, one
of the humanity's big problems
is this overidentification with something
that is a thought that you have
and a way that you identify yourself.
Like I talked about a second ago,
like this division that is in our country.
And by having, once you identify
yourself with an opinion,
you actually translate your own existence
into that opinion being
maintained and spread.
And that's where it gets into this like,
trying to protect your own existence.
So what I'm saying is, is that
I identify myself with this argument,
because I feel like if I can
get you to agree with me,
if I can get you to
think like I do on this,
then that kind of validates me,
it validates my own existence.
And if I'm not able to do
that and I've identified,
I've placed some of my
own personal identity
in that position, if
that position isn't true
there's a little bit less than me around.
It's a fascinating concept.
You're saying you discovered
this about yourself
more so than you're saying,
I discovered how everybody operates.
I think I had this realization
that both things were happening,
because the first thing that happened
is this overwhelming like sense of burden
about how divided the country is.
And being really mad about
the country being divided.
And also having a very
interesting perspective
that I bring to that
because I'm somebody that's been on
both sides of the political
spectrum in my adult life.
So I feel like I have an
appreciation for both sides,
it's like, I know how conservatives think
and I know how liberals think
because I've had very
similar thought patterns
to both of them.
But then realizing that on a small scale,
and maybe an inconsequential
scale, I had demonstrated
that I'm just as big
a part of the problem,
just in that little conversation we had.
Now, I appreciate what people had to say
when they were like,
oh, I'm so glad you guys
had that conversation.
And you're able to have like this conflict
without being mad at each other
and you kind of demonstrated
how to have healthy conflict.
And if that's what came
from it, then great,
I'm glad we had the conversation.
But I realize that not
just that conversation,
but the way that I think in general,
even when I did my deconstruction story,
as much as I was trying really hard,
because I know my
tendency, to be persuasive,
but just to be expository
and just tell my story.
I know that I have a tendency,
I want to justify myself.
I want to validate my own position
because I've got a big ego.
And I want to perpetuate my own ideas
because I have over identified
with ideas as inconsequential
as thinking that you need to
realize how competitive you are
and the details of the argument are kinda,
they don't even matter.
It just becomes this.
I just kinda like I dug in and said,
let's have this conversation
and hopefully it will end
with you agreeing with me.
And I think that that is,
it's a small picture of what's happening
not just nationwide, but worldwide.
It's just a preoccupation
with being right.
You know what I'm saying?
Identifying with an idea
and then being validated in that idea.
Because that validates you as
a person, or people as people.
And the way that ideology,
identification with a
particular political party,
particular worldview,
particular religion, whatever,
it comes with a whole set of things
that you have to embrace, right?
Like how did it ever get to the point
where identifying as a follower of Jesus
went hand in hand with being
extremely capitalist, right?
How did, how did we get to a place
where identifying yourself
as a follower of Jesus
meant denying that humans are
causing climate change, right?
I think we got there
because it's a package,
you take the package.
Listen, I'm not judging,
what I'm saying is that
I'm guilty of it as well.
I'm beginning to try to explore,
okay, well, where else
has this manifested itself
outside of just a dumb argument
about how competitive you are.
But ultimately what I'm saying is that,
we had that conversation and
it became this big thing,
not even because I thought
that it was important,
but because I made the statement
and then I felt like I had to defend it,
I felt like I had to defend it for an hour
worth of conversation.
You know, I think that
that's not the typical,
that's not how things typically play out
in our friendship dynamic.
I think it wasn't what
you expected to happen.
Again, it was like you thought
there would be a little
playful conversation
and then an agreement.
I think with a lot of things
going through life together,
there has been this dynamic of, you know,
if we're exploring an idea or,
if you're more intent
on exploring an idea,
then you can bounce it off of me
and more often than not, I
would explore it with you
and validate that position.
Mm-hmm.
I do think that's an interesting
dynamic that, you know,
I didn't realize was happening.
And it was like, if someone
was looking at my life
they might say, well,
you just glom on to whatever
Rhett believes or whatever.
Or, you believe whatever he tells you,
would be like a severe and
non charitable way to put it,
'cause that's not actually true.
But what I never thought of
is with you like talking about how this,
'cause I didn't I didn't
know how this worked
in your own mind, but if
hearing that someone may say,
Link fulfills a role in your life
to validate that part of yourself
that's associated with ideas.
Potentially.
Again, I don't know, but it does,
I do see, I mean, there is
that pattern because I think,
again, you're exploring
how you interact with ideas
and identity and again, it's
like, I don't have to say
I have that exact same experience
in order to validate your
realization or your confession.
Or me to say, I don't relate to that.
It's like, this conversation's
not about me at all.
It's 'cause I mean, it's
one thing to be like,
so are you saying you shouldn't
have opinions about things
or you shouldn't argue for things?
It's like, well, I mean,
I think we're in a place in our country
where I think that there are principles
and there are people that
need to be advocated for
and there are things that
need to be stood for.
So I think that being
a person of principle,
of character and integrity
and standing for things,
I'm not saying you shouldn't
have opinions and convictions.
But we've talked about how we also value,
I mean, with our deconstruction stories,
how much we value open-mindedness
and like not skipping
from one entrenched thing,
belief system, just to another one.
But it's less about
where we're entrenched,
that's a different conversation,
than just talking about
our value of open-mindedness
and not ruling anything out in order to.
Well, and I think that the challenge is
finding a way to have an
opinion, a belief, a conviction,
to fight for something, but
not to overly identify with it
to the point that your self
worth and your self identity
is based in some position
that you have, right?
Because at that moment
you become more committed to your position
than you do to the human
race, to the greater good.
That's a selfish, it actually
becomes a selfish pursuit.
And I just, in that
podcast I demonstrated how
that can happen with
something so unimportant
as me thinking that you're competitive.
Like, what if it was having
an argument about abortion?
You know, for God's sake, right.
But no, I wasn't even
talking about something
that has any emotional weight to it,
I was just talking about whether
or not you're competitive.
It came from a conversation
about board games,
but yet even then I was willing to,
and I was a very willing participant
in identifying with that position
and once I threw it out there
and it encountered some resistant energy,
I energized the side of my conversation
to try to get my energy
to beat your energy
so I could be like my energy
wins and I won this argument.
And I just feel like that negative energy
that's happening on both sides,
it's happening on both sides
of the spectrum at this point,
is like, there's just
something that's been lost.
And I'm a part of it, I'm
saying that I am a part of it.
But I'm realizing that I want
to be a part of the solution
and not just contribute to the noise.
I don't really know what that looks like.
I don't have any application.
And ultimately, I'm not encouraged,
so I'm not gonna end it on a happy note.
For me personally I'm encouraged
with some of the things that have happened
and that one of the
things is like, oh man,
you tend to want to debate or
argue or you want to be right
and that's not about wanting
people to understand the truth
as much as it's about you
wanting to be right, your ego.
I'm glad that I'm
beginning to realize that.
But the thing that is discouraging
is our interconnectedness that
we've been able to achieve
given the proliferation of
the internet has backfired.
and we're way less connected
I think, than we've ever been.
And it does not seem to be,
there doesn't seem to be any
sort of resolution in sight.
And instead of commenting on that
I'll take an aside and just say,
since this is the time
where we're talking about,
if this is the followup
to the competition,
I'll just give like the concise
way that I've processed it.
I think for me, I didn't
read a lot of the comments.
I had discussions with,
you know, with Christie,
I might've had a therapy
discussion about it,
I may not have.
But one of the things that kinda,
when I look back on the conversation now
is the thing that I carry with me is,
I realized that it was, you know,
unpacking like the competitive,
your competitive nature.
You know, I very much internalized that
as kind of, as a threat, right.
And then what I,
part of my process was
kind of coming through that
and saying, you know what?
Analyzing that but then also realizing
that if the thing that sticks with me,
the positive thing from
the conversation is that
if there's a competitive spirit between us
and it doesn't just go one
way, and I'm not denying that,
I'm not saying I'm not competitive at all.
But I am asserting that I am not the same,
I'm not the same as you in this way.
That I think what it kind of hurt
because I felt threatened by it.
The turn was actually being honored by it.
Like if you, you're not
competitive with everybody,
if there is a competitive
spirit from you towards me,
then I can take, I honestly
take that as a compliment.
That is a level of respect
that I didn't immediately experience,
but the more I thought about
it and reflected on it,
I was like, that's my takeaway from it.
So it's, you know, I
take it as a compliment.
Okay, good.
And yeah, I do find it fascinating that
because there's mics in front of us
it changes the dynamic of the
conversation a little bit,
but the conversation that we had afterward
for the next two hours, you know,
there was a lot of good
that came from that too,
that, you know, didn't need to be on mic
and I think it was a milestone
moment, and a good thing.
I'm glad we had the conversation.
I just have come to grips
with why I push things the way that I did.
And some people were really, you know,
some people really,
really picked up on that.
And ironically, or I guess not
so ironically, but fittingly,
even my competitive
nature in a lot of ways
is based in the way that how I identify,
what I identify with and what
I find my worth in, right.
And a lot of times I find my
worth in winning at things.
And again, that's just another
displacement of my identity
into this performance,
meeting some expectation,
whether it's set by me
or set by somebody else.
So even the argument that I was having
was trying to get you to realize
that you think about this
in the same way that I do.
The thing I was trying
to get you to think about
was also a symptom of my ego
and the way I was doing it
was a symptom of my ego.
And none of this is like
super revolutionary,
it isn't like if you had a told me that
before that conversation, I
probably would've been like,
yeah, that's true, wanting to be right
and wanting to have an argument
and kind of digging into
your trench in an argument
is based in ego,
but I don't feel like I had a,
to get back what we're talking about,
an experiencial knowledge.
A heart knowledge.
I could agree with it intellectually.
But now I'm like, oh, I can feel that.
And I think I have just
a little bit more sort of
consciousness of that tendency.
So when I go there, when
I find myself going there,
when I'm in and when I find
myself suddenly in an argument
being like, whoa, whoa, whoa,
has this suddenly shifted?
Do you care anymore about
whether or not what the truth is?
Or do you just care about being right?
Because it feels like our
culture has gotten to a place
where the only thing anyone
cares about is just being right.
Well, I think that what you're describing,
sharing your experience is
a source of hope, you know.
At least we got this one
data point, you know,
and I want to be that
person too, that's like,
I'm not gonna hold on
to something so tightly
that I lose myself, who
I really want to be.
And I think, so, I understand
why you're saying it's like,
I'm not really ending on a hopeful note,
but at the same time, I think
that there's a hopeful takeaway.
Well, I hope so.
And we should go, you know,
I'm sayin', we should
make sure we pick dates
and that we go off again.
Well, and that's my recommendation,
it's very simple, it's very general.
Make time for yourself, we
did the whole chapter and.
Isolate yourself with yourself.
Yeah, and, you know, it's something that I
knew was important.
That, you know, my therapist
is telling me, you need this.
I'm believing that I need this,
but it took me, I mean,
I did my little trip
to the place with the
yoga thing and the hot tub
back, you know, a couple of years ago.
But it was different, it felt different.
But just making that time for yourself,
you may not be in a position,
especially given the
circumstances in the world,
to travel right now.
But like, there's just something about
giving yourself some space,
releasing yourself of
expectations, responsibilities,
the need to accomplish something,
and just letting yourself off the hook
and really spending some time
just discovering yourself.
And for me it was helpful to get away
and also to read a few books
that had been recommended to me.
Which again, I'm not gonna
recommend those books.
You don't have to read what I read,
it's just, that was for me.
But yeah, make some time for yourself,
isolate yourself with yourself.
That's my rec.
#EarBiscuits, let us know.
We'll speak at you next week.
To watch more Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your mythical best.